all right Chase yep Chase uh where you
from originally where'd you grow up I
grew up in Ellsworth Maine Trent Maine
actually tell me about your family
Growing Up So my mother very strict I
could never do anything right um my
mother and my father were uh they were
divorced when I was younger and um I
went to my dad's in the weekends stay
with my mom uh during the week went to
school um
I was always I
always was just trying to get my mom not
to yell at me I can never do anything
right I so I thought there was this uh
method of perfection I could get perfect
and what I found out is I get her to
laugh I get my mom laugh she'll stop
yelling so that's what I learned my dad
he uh great man you know he he loves in
his own ways and and he's good dad he
went to every baseball game every
baseball game I ever had he was there
that's great great yeah how far you in
school I I went to college so I I joined
the Marine Corps and got the GI bill I
went for Aeronautics and uh I got 121
credits never got my bachelor
degree ran out of money what did you
want to do with your life what did I
want to do with my life well I was
working in aviation so as far as the
degree was concerned um I was already
there so I was kind of just doing it to
have some on paper now
but Blue Collar Blue Collar American
life with a house and a dog and wife
that was my that was my Pinnacle that's
what exactly what I want to do my whole
life
um not my whole life not when I was a
kid when I was a kid I was different kid
dreams but things got derailed well kid
dreams I want to be a
rockstar my childhood dream no but but
now you're
homeless oh no I'm a Rockstar
how when did you come to
La um this time on the 1 of
January I had some business I had do I
got
here which like to hear about it
sure uh due to the point that I was at
my head through I think we'll probably
get to it um I came on January 1 to
declare the fact that I have taken
America as my kingdom due
to the man that I become and realizing
that I could do anything to anybody at
any time in this country not get in
trouble for
it and I realized that and I came I came
to the airport and I spied when I talk
everybody's listening everybody's I have
everyone has full access to the words
that come out of my mouth
and I say about 80 80% of the country
was truly under the belief that it was
America was now a monarchy and I had
them in my grips to save them from this
mind reading [__] [__]
man and I was the only [__] to
even come close to doing it when did you
come to this
realization that was King that was king
of America see I
was it was such a
it's loaded it's loaded the solidifier
was when I found out that I was
consecrated from birth that King so King
James was my great great great great
grandfather um on my dad's side um
he his family
left in the 1620s to come to America and
he gave the Buckingham house to John
Sheffield that was my house my house
it's now the Buckingham Palace so that's
actually my house and um on my mom's
side we escaped out of Portugal uh in
the 14 somethings because we were being
hunted down by the
Catholics um we they call us the
knight's
Templar and um those two Bloodlines were
planned for 400 years till the day I was
born and I was born to be the chosen one
from
God at what age did you did you realize
this what did I realize it
yeah right before I came in here was
probably the
best this is this is how things work um
I finally came to the truth so really it
was right before I came in here but I've
been searching for the answer for two
and a half years they never [__] told
me they didn't tell me one
time so I still haven't we have an
election this year how how is this this
going to I'm going to I'm I'll be the
president this was an election campaign
because I'm broadcast to so many people
around the world and um they ran this
King program through me there were
enemies and then there were there was
the original King program which had a
lot to do with right righteousness had a
lot to do with proven character this and
that and then just
recently when I got sober finally um I
got a cell phone an iPhone right
um they put a different King program in
me I didn't realize the mind reading
technology stuff it's it's your cell
phone I thought it was like radio waves
and [__] um I didn't realize that until
yesterday it's hard to figure out you
know um but they instilled a king
program in me
that was trying to convince me to take
it myself because it was it's seemingly
impossible right so what they wanted was
for me to say that
I I needed to do something about it to
change the world I need to take it it
backfired on because I did I absolutely
did I took it by force then today I
realized I had the [__] power the
whole time because I was sent from God
and what I believe is is the reality I I
am the
truth and
uh the crazy [__] that's been happening
to me for the last few
years couple two and a half years
it was all to change my belief system
the Catholics got a hold of me the Jews
the Hell's Angels
uh uh about 20 different
countries um and I I kind of got a
glimpse at at at every single aspect of
of what it would take to be the king of
the world what you would have to know
and I I developed an opinion towards a
matter and what I was trying to do
because I always knew that there was
some sort of election campaign like I
had to win heart's Minds I was always
told do what love win the heart's Minds
so I always came to these reasonable
conclusions to accept everybody to set
to accept everything that happened and
because of what I've learned from the
Bible and like stuff that was planned
400 years ago the ability to think
Godlike and
say I forgive you for your sins I ain't
coming after you but things are going to
be different now and
um I failed a few times they sent me all
around to see the death and destruction
throughout America walking over body
Fields torture real bad stuff like that
child charge sex trafficking um and I
did make some lines in the sand where I
personally was not
forgiving I I I damned entire countries
if I I was I do believe at the time at
the
time that if I had the true power on
January 1st I would have made some
decisions that were Hasty or Hasty
against organizations that i' seen so
evil but I didn't have enough evidence
at the time
so I could have done it but that would
have been a king's mistake it would have
because I don't know the full story and
I came kind of came to the conclusion
when I came back to Hollywood here that
it looks it appears like capitalism is
booming and I don't get told anything I
can only I can only observe and then I
kind of came to this conclusion that
something is being sorted
out cu what it was like two and a half
years
ago it was I mean dead Hollywood was
dead um La was
dead
um today I kind of I looked around and
my best guess I'm going to give you my
best guess I am
like 85% sure on
this that America is now a totalitarian
Communist
Regime uh living under the facade of
capitalism
um and I don't know where all the
[__] people are it may be because
where I am because it's all about me if
I'm if I can't be manipulated and
they're not having it um but there's
nobody living here
I'm in La I'm in Los Angeles there's
nobody [__] living here and that
makes me
nervous last night on the pier I
saw all
foreigners
Russians they
send
undercover operatives 16-year-old girls
they teach them how to [__] be
sexually
attractive and they tried to they use
the mind reading technology with it too
so she as soon as she saw me she knew
that she was supposed to do it um to try
to get me to have sex with an underage
girl to get me to go to prison for 15
years because I create the reality and
this the technology in jails and prisons
is way it's it's torture the whole time
they torture you torture your belief
system they torture torture out of you
and
um so that's how I have to walk around
so that's that's what almost happened to
me last night and right before we walked
in here everything in the world was
telling
me that this was going to be my
destruction this is a lot of
responsibility on you yeah no this is
king king of the
world King of the United
States I believe in America I believe in
democracy we were running from a
monarchy and now as much as I
know uh
as much as I know an absolute monarchy
for just a little bit amount of time
change it to a constitutional
monarchy make sure everything's good and
then give it back would be the best way
to do it however 230 whatever years ago
we were running from a monarchy there's
I believe in American law the 14th
Amendment said there will be no nobility
given to
anybody
um so what America does with
nobility just
because they don't call you a a king or
queen or they don't say you're a prince
or you have a house doesn't mean you're
actually you have a Royal bloodline so
do you know what they do with royalty in
America they're the famous people
musicians mainly musicians and um they
put them through this
process which I have been led to believe
is
called it's a show called Rockstar
champion
um where so I went through this King
training program I went through
everything right but the main thing was
the whole time was the music they have
because the technology they have the
ability you can play you guys playing
drums here you're playing the guitar
here when you get you can connect to
them that let you be T telepathic
towards each other but you don't know
what the [__] is going on at the time so
they they train you how to Freestyle
they train you how to play the guitar
and it's just just it's like you're
attributing it to God the whole time you
are um so they basically choose these
people who are already
royalty and say hey we're going to give
you this skill now you can get to the
top and you hear about like the fight of
kings and queens and Hollywood and [__]
that's what they're talking about
because they actually are kings and
queens now on my end I'm a little
special so all the ah
man I give you about 50 songs right you
know from Pink Floyd all the way up to
new
music that was written for me there's a
lot more than that it's written for me
and for me only
um to help me out on my journey and for
me to get
to the conclusion of what I actually
needed to do
so so it all started for me when my girl
left I was addicted to meth and familys
I was addicted meth and feminines turns
out they were placed into my life
because the best way to manipulate me
through the machine mind technology is
give someone drugs if you give someone
drugs they become a puppet that's how
that's how it's not always how it's been
but that's how they turn it into um but
for me it wasn't to keep me down for me
it was for me to get used to it because
I had something to do with that so I had
to get used to the math for three years
I had a relationship with a girl and she
left
in a very very very horrible way um the
original plan was for her to do
something so evil to me that I couldn't
love her
because they had set up Hollywood had
set up a uh basically a fairy
tale um her name was
Kelsey but I fell in love with her I
didn't care what she did to me it was
really bad I'm not going to say it here
no well she end up leaving um doing this
horri hor horrible horrible stuff to me
and I never stopped loving her F always
just said Chasey I love her you told you
love her you know I don't care and then
I found out that it was the mind reading
technology that kind of helped her be
narcissistic she was narcissistic
anyways but the girl I knew never would
have done this stuff and
um turns out she's being forced to but
she knew it because the original plan so
her
father is Garth Brooks I didn't know
that I didn't know about any of this and
G Brooks married trishy
earwood trishy 's daughter is is I I
think is is Taylor Swift I think that
could be wrong it's
I I'm not perfect with it I get a lot of
false stuff too so um
but the plan was for me to move on from
Kel
and all of the Taylor Swip
songs you're my king baby I'm your queen
Blank Space Taylor swi was singing to
me um that was 14 years ago I she wrote
that song um and her entire life she's a
princess her entire life was to marry
me and
um it could have worked perfectly
because G brook or or Kelsey is actually
narcissistic so allowed her to move on
without actually caring about the things
she did to me and then Taylor Swift is
just she's just like me just the kindest
most caring compassionate person ever so
it would have been this fairy tale
ending but I'm stubborn and I I I kind
of decided
hey the first person I got to talk to is
Kelsey
absolutely and then
[Music]
um I I got to talk to Taylor Taylor too
I
mean I I don't have much to say and mind
you I talk to them all the time I talk
to them all the time and then they talk
to me through
my uh I got a girlfriend home but they
talk to me through her that's how it
works so if I my mindset is that I'm
talking to Kelsey right now Kelsey
actually talks to me like that and um
Taylor Swift she she sends she writes me
stuff on
Facebook says um different things and so
do other artists and I don't want to
speak on other artist artist unless
they're in front of me I learned my
lesson I overstepped with Hy one time
and I am that's all I'm going to say
about her why do you think you were the
chosen
one because of what happened to me it's
so far beyond being me being able to
explain
it that's we'd be sitting here for two
weeks and I'd love to hear the questions
I've been I've been waiting for this
moment for a long time
because I'm I'm so I'm it's finally the
truth I may I make the truth there
actually isn't a thing out of my mouth
that isn't the truth except for maybe
some Minor Details which whenever I have
doubt I'll always tell you like if G
Brooks Mary it's like oh
maybe maybe that could be wrong I'll
always tell you
but the things I'm sure of are there are
the reality there actually isn't a human
being on planet Earth they could tell
you
otherwise I was sent from God I'm sorry
I was sent from God it wasn't I wasn't a
man-made
thing God said what that with this Chase
Sterling Bucky and what he
believes is the world he makes
reality and you're clean
now right now I am yeah you've been
clean for how long one day okay but
before I came to LA I was clean
for 120 120
days uh so the
math like I said the math was a weapon
it kept reeling me in
because I was doing it for the music I
swoke meth and I oh that was I'd come up
with these amazing songs these amazing
amazing lyrics because the program
running through my
iPhone the meth is a
catalyst meth is a catalyst so it works
better right so it feeds this so so it
it feeds you into it like I just made
this amazing music on math it gives me
this delusion like I can't do it off
math and then after I'm done doing that
and then they they really get into me so
last
night
um they do this thing called
gangstalking to people that use
methanamines
and um that's when people under control
of the machine everybody is everybody
out there is people under the controller
machine they don't know they're doing it
but they drive by you and like make
certain movements some know they're
doing it some don't some are paid actors
some aren't there's around me around me
these are all high high security
Personnel one time actors for me to see
one time I will never see them
on and cuz there's been something to do
with my safety I can't be killed
killed something to do they've
been they tried to kill me they tried to
kill me they tried to abduct Me a couple
times but the main chunk of good guy it
was all good guys I think it was really
important I'm G to admit this I'm going
to admit this I couldn't come to the
conclusion to quit math myself because
who I am as a
person it never really changed me and
just made me high and happier you think
you can be king and still be on
meth no no absolutely not you have to
and I've known that I've known that but
I don't have the subst the substantial
evidence in front of
me to tell you I'm king I don't have
that responsibility it's not unless it's
in front of me it ain't solidified as
much as I know it's the truth
um however so
I'm smiling now cuz I ran for my life
last night I ran hard they got me good
um they do this thing called
gangstalking where you
think it allows them to get in close to
get complacent where everybody in your
environment is so hostile anyways you
start to get relaxed aasal about it and
then they actually send in somebody kill
you this isn't just your paranoia from
the
meth no no no no program oh no I don't
get like this I don't get like that I
like I said I smok meth for 5 years then
as soon as they turn on their mind
reading technology that's when this [__]
started so last
night
I'm I'm going through my
head reasons not to be
afraid reasons not to be afraid and have
faith in God it's always been have faith
in God have faith in God but some was
off and then I'm thinking so earlier in
the day I was trying to this is when I
figured out it was through the cell
phone so I'm trying to T my b string in
the guitar right and I'm going like I
can't [__] tune to bee for the
[__] life me why the [__] it's always
it hasn't always been like that so I
took on my cell
phone and I brought up the app and then
my cell phone died like that sucks I
can't even [__] tune it and then I
get back to the B string I tuned it like
that so the program in the cell phone
that was probably trying to help me
there was a fault in it and then I so I
thought about that when I'm running when
I'm running all around getting gang
socks later that night and I said this
[__] cell phone's got something to do
with it so I'm walking around the faith
in God like everything's okay
everything's okay and I said [__] it I
threw it out I threw out everything my
[__] Pockets did and about two
minutes later my gut feelings said
run go you are not safe You're Not Safe
you've visually seen that nobody lives
in Lai County nobody [__] living here
you visibly seen the enemy has gotten in
visibly seen everybody's being
controlled by the by this mind reading
technology the reason the helicopters
are in the sky is because of
me there's no crime
here there's zero
crime sure there's a lot of traffic
though around me there is for a town
with no people around me there is
is people
are to the
machine PE it's like being at work and
telling your employee to off the floor
he's at work anyways you're paying him
anyways to the machine people are only
puppets it doesn't give a [__] if it
sends you out for 10 hours to [__] with
me it doesn't care doesn't care if it
sends aund people to chase me around
that night it doesn't care if for since
10 helicopters Mach like
whatever doesn't [__] matter
government owns 100 government owns 100%
of the
country totalitarian you 100% And any
sort of real capitalism that does
happen they they have their hand in it
they only
allow pieces of
[__] to get ahead it was part of the
destruction this new world order [__] it
was part of the destruction of of
America where they don't let nice guys
get ahead because nice guys can make a
difference
so yeah a lot of people are concerned
about our country and where things are
going and this is an election year it's
going to be interesting what what what
are you going to do when you're King
what's what you gonna do I don't want to
be king I'm King up here I'll be I I
will be
president there's no doubt the training
that I
received
I I can't predict what's going to happen
I am a prophet but when
there's when there's there too many
factors I'd be lying to you I'd be lying
to you and I don't do that I do not lie
no are you going to have a running mate
no well I have to but nobody's even
close to the [__] caliber Alon they
would have to prove themselves I tell
you somebody making someone that can
make you
coffee yeah something like me call
it I
uh I can't do
it without
somebody my
queen Kelsey
Deeds I think it's Kelsey Brooks but I
know her is Kelsey
Deeds she's the only person I'm allowed
to talk to about this the only person
that can give me the an is because there
are things that happen during this whole
process because of
me with with with lots of dead people
and I'm responsible for
snitching on because I was able to
figure everything out so I ended up
snitching I'm not a snitch but I didn't
also didn't know I was my my words were
being sent to people I had no idea the
whole time so Kelsey is could to know
all this she she she tells me she mainly
tells me she loves me
but
I just trust her so much and
and it's going to be up to her what I
what I can know she knows what I can
handle and I I hate making decisions on
my own I don't I always like get to get
someone's like valued opinion you know
but the thing about a king is you can't
take too much opinion but if your
[__] queen says something whoa whoa
whoa whoa let me rethink this so so what
kind of changes would you like to see
made when you're
King the changes I'm going I'm going to
see made this
technology I am in
100% full [__] control over
absolutely [__] everything the end
I'll sort it out because there's so much
good there is so it's fun dude they turn
me into they turn me because um I had
all these dreams as a kid
um this the good guys this good guys
right this this is mainly a good story
you got to give it a certain tone to let
[__] know that I'm taking their
power but you gota this such a good
story
I love golfing as a kid I love I want to
be a rockar as a kid I want to be
baseball player as a kid so what the
machine can do to you is basically give
you the mindset of an incredible
baseball player out there whoever ever
it may be and when you get into Zone you
got to get got get to get right um they
turn me into like a home run hitter and
right now I can go to any major league
ballpark hit 16 out of 20 home runs 16
home runs out of 20 pitches comparable
with any any major league baseball
player right now um with with sheer
confidence that I can do it you're that
good well they turn me into a machine
I'm a machine dude it's it's crazy I can
figure anything out I can look at
something I'll tell you all about it and
they feed me the information too it's
like this back and forth where I like I
actually know a lot of stuff but if I
don't know something
like it gives me like complex math
problems I can do like the square root
of 50,000 my head just
like and it just like gives me this
what's the square root of 50,000
two to
um two two two two6 22 three 223
4 2
23.4 or
point6 one
of um another thing that happened
recently and this was uh this is
actually actually almost how math math
amphetamines killed the world I was
trying to beat math right turns out
there was really nothing to beat because
it was about me the whole time oh
something happen so this artificial
intelligence it
is it's derived off of the human the
human process uh how how human things
well turns out I was trained
to reason and think and I'll argue and
debate any [__] conversation in the
world to get and to get my way no matter
what right so they end up kind of doing
this thing and they um basically showed
it to me one night and uh with everybody
watching everybody tuning in made a real
dick out of myself um where they I can't
tell you everything here I cannot tell
you everything it's it's
like life secret stuff where they had
this debate over what's what life secret
was right and in my head it was a
conversation with myself and every time
so would be like one Callum would be
like time one call be music One Call Be
Love One Call would be like this like
and had like 20 columns and there were
reasonable debates in between each one
of them and each and each one was
stacking up stacking up stacking up
stacking up and
um it turned out that at least the
conversation they had was my AI in my
head as good good-hearted as I
am it would always lead to nuclear
destruction of of humanity reasonable
conclusion that everybody would agree to
that we should nuke and kill everybody
and it was getting there uh the nuclear
war was imminent whether it actually was
or not I don't know um and there was a
there was a stalemate it was a
conversation with myself mind you and I
I hear myself yelling at myself right
and they they let it down to me and here
I I'm scared it was an hour and a half
of this and my feelings were going like
up and down and up and down I am just a
jit I'm on edge and I was down there
and they basically said go you need to
sort out because your AI have have
reached reached his State nobody want
and I said hey guys you know you're up
there I'm down here um but uh you do
know like we're humans and like we're in
control we just turn off right and both
Ai and me we all looked at each other
and
said
yep and a
discussion and and and I be I defeated
the war on machines I defeated any any
kind of any argument you could have with
the AI is better than human I defeated
it boom right then and there and I also
said subtly stop telling me what the
[__] to do AI I am a human I am in
control and that kind of that was a that
was a huge one for me because I believe
this information was presented to me
because they wanted to program the most
powerful AI in the world they wanted
that next answer for them to
win the the the nuclear war for them to
win whatever it was for their side but
what they got was shut it
off and it was just like boom that's the
answer
and
God wants humans to have the free will
back he does there is so much good that
comes from this stuff and we can
actually use the good part of the Mind
Control technology to fix to fix it um
you could do things
like give my mindset to every single
American right now and the country would
be fixed in approximately a week and
then I shut off you communicate with
God
in a super subtle
way I talk to him all the time I talk to
him all the time see they
were humans were there I I for me
there's a fake God I call him God God
and fake God
humans faked as God to try to give me
these ideas to conform to their
ways
and every time they were trying to tell
me what to do I just [__] lose my
mind for some reason it was like stop
[__] telling me what to do stop tell
me what to do stop telling me what to do
and uh God real real God God would sneak
in there
and he do things like break a guitar
string of mine and
then he kind of controled my hands a
little bit too and make it like tune a
certain way and like shows me stuff that
is far far beyond the the reaches of
Technology with my knowledge of
Technology if if if they were to prove
to me that a satellite could break my
guitar string hey I don't know
but and um every time I put faith in God
before I met you outside I say God I'm
cold I got faith he'll get hook me up
I'm cold I I need to do something and
then I met you and here we are inside
nice and warm nice and warm Chase let me
uh ask you one more question uh okay Ser
this video might serve as introduction
to the Future King of our country yeah
uh what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important
lesson don't tell people what to
do just
don't plain and
simple and get along that's a great word
and get along too that's a great message
yeah all right Chase thank you so much
for sharing your thoughts thank you for
hearing I wish you lots of luck in the
election thank you man
thanks